In our model, the number of susceptible persons always decreases.
It cannot have any component here with a + sign and leave this blank.
And similarly, the number of recovered persons always increases.
It cannot have something with a - sign here.
A certain fraction of the infectious persons is taken per day to the recovered compartment.
What worked best is 1/5 days, b times well the number of infectious persons f.
We need the same here with a - sign.
Everybody who leaves the infectious compartment joins the recovered compartment.
The similar process is in place with e and i. Exposed persons become infectious afterwards.
The rate should be a, 1/1 day seems to be plausible latency of 1 day
times the number of exposed persons.
Certain fraction of the exposed persons per day gives the exposed compartment
and joins the infectious compartment.
That same number that leaves here has to joint here, a,e and here we have the infectious process.
The number of exposed, infected that is, persons increases per day by 5*10⁻⁹/day
times the product of the number of infectious persons times the number of susceptible persons.
So, it's c, h and what we gained here, we have to use here, c, h.
There's one thing to keep in mind though. This latency period of one day is an average.
It's not a strict number similar to this recovery period of 5 days. These are average numbers.
The small percentage of exposed infected disease persons will be taken pretty quickly
to the infectious state and the small percentage will take quite a while to get to the infectious state.
This times of 1 day and 5 days are not rigid. They are averages.